Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
This will be my Full
Loki season 2 Episode 4 Video
There were a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references,
so we'll break it all down.
Just R.I.P.
to the entirety of the MCU multiverse.
Like all of reality just collapsed.
We had a good run, guys.
Everybody pack it up.
We'll start again with like another
big giant franchise of superhero movies.
no joke.
There are a lot of ramifications
for the end of this episode.
So if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe
to get all the episodes.
There are still two to episodes
left in season
two, and Kevin Feige
even commented on Loki Season three.
that's why the ending is so interesting
because like R.I.P.
all of reality,
the entire multiverse, all timelines
just in general, just broke down.
How are they going to save themselves
in the last two episodes?
how do you save yourself
when all of reality is completely gone?
And it's just this void of nothingness?
but before we get too deep into the weeds
on it.
Careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet.
Just because they to talk about everything
Just starting at the beginning
of the episode, working our way through.
Shot by shot.
Talking about Easter eggs wtf moments,
starting with the episode title
The heart of the TVA,
which is both a reference
to missed minutes and the temporal core.
Like the actual timeline itself
here in the loom
Miss Minutes
is the metaphorical heart of the TVA
because she has administrator
access to all our systems
and she's more advanced than Ultron.
So literally she can control everything
in the TVA from the ground up.
during the episodes,
she minds up sabotaging everything
till they're able to kick her out
by rebooting the systems in the temporal
core here, where they're repairing
the loom is the literal heart of the TVA.
I actually think that their solution
to fixing the Ms..
Menace problem
by rebooting the TVA systems completely
is going to be the solution that they use
to fix all the timelines in episodes
five and six like rebooting the timeline,
so to speak.
are a lot of people that actually wondered
if we'd ever actually traveled
to like the very beginning of the timeline
because so much of Loki season one
was all about traveling
to the very end of the timeline
where he who remains Citadel
at the end of time was but
he basically implied that by killing him
it would cause the timeline to reboot.
And I think we're just seeing a version
of that play out during Loki season two.
Like the timeline itself
will have to be rebooted, so to speak.
Who knew that fixing all of reality
would be as simple as fixing
your router in your Internet at home.
Literally looks like what's happening
in Loki Episode four five and six.
Like the unplug the timelines, like
everything is gone, the void of
nothingness before the Big Bang,
then boom, everything comes back again.
we kind of saw a version of that
during Loki season one, Episode six in the
finale.
like you see all of creation
just collapsing and then like a version,
the Big Bang happens again,
like the timeline restarts again.
It has that black hole.
You see the sacred timeline
heading to the end of time.
effect, I think that's the reason why
they start the episode
with that special version,
the intro where you rush like
you hear the rushing sound
as you rush into the Marvel Studios logo
and into the timeline.
but. In the actual opening scene,
the version of the timeline that we see
is is exists now with all the different
branches going all over the place.
There's supposed to be infinite branches
now, like theoretically infinite
timelines.
the opening scene is also a reference
to the opening scene from Loki.
Season one, Episode six
Like it's a callback to that
because you're kind of
doing the same thing
where you travel through the timeline
to the end of time, But in this version,
it basically picks up right in the moments
that we left off in episode three,
Miss Minutes
explains the rest of rent player's
backstory in the thing, quote unquote,
that she was going to reveal to her.
The secret that she would like
is basically what we thought
in episode three.
Like,
the big theory is that she just tell her
the rest of her
origin story Miz Miss basically gives her
like an instant replay like a home
movie of the events that Loki listened to
on the tape during episode one.
Like the exact same conversation,
but in video form,
the way they explain her backstory
is that Renslayer
was he who remains general
during the king Multiverse war.
He had this giant army working for him
like King usually does in the comics.
as they're talking, they're finishing
the construction of the TVA.
It sounds like they've been building it
for a while and they're just putting
the finishing touches on it right now.
so his army were made up
of all the people who became TVA
agents and are working at the TVA prison
they like KC, was also part of his army.
Mobius was part of his army
during the Kane multiverse war.
minute that he would have pulled them
from different parts of the timeline
where they originally came,
like their original lives many years
before the creation of the TVA,
this is a pretty critical detail
because during Loki season one,
they kind of made it seem like
most of the TVA agents were taken
after the creation of the TVA,
like they became variants
at some point that the TVA was created.
Then the TVA either pruned them
or turned them into more agents.
but the way they talk about them
during the flashback here,
they make it sound like everybody.
Mobius, for example,
became part of he who remains army long
before the creation of the TVA
India, the really important detail here
too is when they're talking to each other.
He remains towards talking about
for all time, always he almost sounds
kind of regretful, whereas Renslayer
seems like she was super hardcore.
like he remains, seems way more
sentimental during their conversation.
The way he's talking about
things than Rentschler does.
Like she seems like
she's all about the business.
Like,
All right, time to go back to the TVA.
Let's do this.
when she returns to the TVA
and he activates Ms.
minutes, she references the chess games
for which she was created, as she talked
about in previous episodes,
like originally,
you just created me
as a robot to play chess with.
And he ordered her to wipe
everyone's memories at the TVA,
explaining how everybody forgot about him
inserted believing in the timekeepers
when he says Protocol 42.
There's also a reference to
The Hitchhiker's Guide
is also a reference to episode two
when Mobius was looking in the TVA journal
and there was a reference to Protocol 42
turns out Protocol
42 is just the protocol to wipe
everyone's minds
the other interesting thing
during their conversation is
that Miss Minutes
seemed kind of reluctant to do that.
Like, are you sure you want to wipe
everyone's memories?
she seems so much more twisted in present
day she leaves to execute that order and
he apologizes to all them to Rensselaer
and pretty much everyone else too.
And he seems very regretful
about what he's doing.
The reason why I think he did that is
to help the TVA function more efficiently
because it everybody remembered everything
about their lives from before.
It would just lead to further problems.
Eventually,
people would be more like Hunter XL5.
I want to go back to my life
like I've lived here for eons.
I want to go back.
during season one,
when Loki and Mobius were joking
about how long they'd actually been there,
Like how long have you worked in
the TVA in movies? Like, I have no idea.
Time works differently here in reality
he'd worked there for eons.
So if he remains had not wiped their minds
or didn't wipe their minds on a regular
basis, slowly
people would just start to break down
like the TVA would stop functioning
the way that it's supposed to.
and it also sounds like he's
kind of regretful about having to kill
all of his different variants
in literally killing
trillions and trillions of other people
in all the other timelines that he erased,
they go pretty deep into that idea
during this episode, like they want
to save all the new branch timelines
because it would theoretically mean saving
trillions of people
Like Loki tells Sylvie that she's a hero
because she saved Victor Timely.
He's going to save the other timelines
in that mean she helped to save
trillions and trillions of people
in all of these different branches
so when Sylvie is talking about killing,
he remains and how he wasn't afraid to die
like Victor time.
He was very afraid to die.
Please don't kill me.
I think what they're implying
in this flashback
is that he felt remorseful
about what he did
and he felt like he deserved to die.
present day Rensselaer also seems
kind of mad when she learns all this too.
Like she feels like
she did all the work of running the TVA
and protecting the sacred timeline.
But he remains took all the credit
but wasn't doing any of the work.
she's kind of taking the wrong lessons
from this,
like she's seeing things
and taking the wrong things out of it
But now that we know some more.
The back story,
if you remember in episode one,
when Loki time slips
to the beginning of the TVA
and he runs into everyone
but they don't remember him
because they haven't met him yet.
But there's still the statue of
he who remains that might be from Mike
right before everybody gets
their minds wiped
or is in the process
of getting their minds wiped
because he who remains, hasn't finished
creating the timekeepers
and replacing that statue of himself
with the timekeepers.
miss minutes then pitches rents
later on an alliance predictably,
that they take over the TVA
and rule all time together.
Like we don't need a king to rule time.
We'll see if there's
any division in the ranks
before the last two episodes are done.
love the way that Victor Timely
also enters the TVA
after the end of episode three.
Like he literally enters in the war room
right in front of the statue of himself
on the wall, Basically, like he sees all
the giant versions of his various face,
he remains yet imagine him
just freaking out like, it's me.
love.
All the scenes of him being super curious,
trying to wander around the hallways
like No, no, no, we need to focus.
We have a problem to fix
Then he finds the mural of the King
Multiverse war, the timekeepers
and pretty much everything,
like the whole dogma of the TVA itself.
And their history.
the reason why Hunter B-15 recognizes him
is because Loki spent all of episode
one trying to catch everyone up on
who King was.
What became Multiverse War was.
But also you remember this means Hunter
B-15 was part of his army
or he remains army
but had her mind wiped to
there's a lot of really serious stuff
but a lot of comedy in between
those serious moments in the episode.
So while they're taking him to meet Ora
Burrows and Casey,
they do have a couple of funny moments
about him getting sidetracked.
Like, Can I go
look at some of these other rooms?
Like, This is all fantastic.
all the scenes of him trying to work out
the time travel logic of it all?
Like, did I create this in the past
or will I create this?
And they try to explain him, No, no, no.
This is a variant of you.
He remains that created this.
they're very careful in this episode
to repeat the idea that he is not
he who remains like he's
a completely different person
when he jokes about Chicago
being the shade ocracy
capital of the world,
that's it's a callback to him
being a confidence trickster
like bilking investors out of money
with his prototypes.
So the idea is that Chicago is meant to be
the capital of the world for tricksters.
So he can see a trick coming a mile away.
notice he refers to Miss Minutes
as the monster clock lady.
I think that's pretty accurate.
Judge Gamble comes back and Hunter B-15
remind me
that they still have general docks
in the holding cells and her agents
sort of work out
the morality of all of these new timelines
and what the new mission,
the TVA's going to become.
Just the whole idea
that Loki was talking to Sylvie about,
like, we can still have the TVA,
the TVA can still be a force for good
their couple jokes with Victor timely
being fascinated by the coffee machine.
I love that idea.
Hot chocolate soup like this
is an actual retro coffee machine.
Like it's a real coffee machine
that they just use in the episode.
I was actually expecting a big twist
with it later.
But it just turns out that Victor
Timely really likes the idea
of getting hot coffee from a machine.
they have all the funny moments of them
meeting each other in Aurora
Burrows is lab like Victor
Timely is a fanboy of Aurora
borrows in Aurora
borrows is a fanboy of Victor timely
and I love the way
that they get into this whole concept too
of the timeline repeating Aura borrows,
which is the title of episode
one The Snake eating its tail
Obi says that he created the
TVA guidebook based on the work of Victor
timely specifically not.
He remains based on the work of Victor.
Timely.
Well, Victor Timely says that he developed
a lot of his work based on the TVA
guidebook created by Obie.
So the whole idea is
how could one influence the other
if one didn't exist before the other?
it's a bit of a callback to that
funny moment that they had in episode one
where Loki's talking to Obi in the past
and then it influences Obi in the future.
it's also a reference to Loki basically
pruning himself like the snake
eating its tail.
Loki is saving himself
with the time slipping from Épisode
one confirming
what was going on in that scene.
They also make
it seem like Obi is a little pissed off.
Is Sylvie because she killed
he who remains causing all the problems
that they're having right now.
Like all of reality is threatened
because she killed he who remains
and she seems super proud that she did
it. Like, Yep, that was me.
I definitely did that.
they're couple of funny moments
with his model, like,
I just whipped up this tiny little thing
with no time at all.
It could have been way better.
I only put a couple coats of paint on it.
but their plan is basically
to make the loom bigger
so that they can just handle
all the different timelines.
Victor timely, then
whips out his life's work and confirms
what he was talking about
in episode three.
So the idea is that
he had the same problem
with his version of the Loom and it wasn't
big enough to handle all the power
This device is a modifier
meant to fix that problem
there are a lot of people after episode
three that thought
that this was meant to be a reference
to his time care, like his time
travel platform during Ant-Man, the WASP
Quantumania but it's just meant to be
a device to modify this like it's
not related to his time travel platform.
they're couple of funny moments
with the key lime pie like we keep going
back to the key lime pie with Mobius
trying to sell Sylvie on the idea,
but she's still pissed off
because of everything that's happening.
she's actually incorrect
that Mobius doesn't care about the other
branch timelines or learning about
his original life on the sacred timeline.
He does want to find out.
He's just afraid of what
that might look like.
Early theory right now is that
it has something to do with jetskis.
And that's why Loki time
slipped to the jetski dealership,
They'll probably pay that scene off
at some point
in one of the last couple of episodes.
maybe.
Mobius used to work at that jet
ski dealership.
he definitely sounds like a professor
of jet skis.
we finally go back to General Docks
in Hunter Z.
Five in the holding cell.
She makes fun of him for this maniac
event.
Like,
that was really spectacular, wasn't it?
He wants to escape and go back to that
life.
Hunter B-15 seems like she almost winds up
winning them over like had Renzulli
or not shown up and had
Miss Minutes not kill them,
she might have actually won them over.
something, getting lost and accidentally
winding up in what she calls pie
land love the way that she describes
it too, might just be a quirk of the way
the TTB was constructed,
like that might be on purpose,
purposely leading people to the M.C.
Escher like construction of the TVA
to make it to this pie place
in Loki basically gives her a version
of the speech like the sage wisdom
that he gave to Mobius,
also eating pie in previous episodes.
he basically tells her
the story of the first Thor movie
in the Sacred Timeline version
where Odin banished Thor to Earth.
How Thor returned being more mature.
But Loki didn't
recognize that at the time
and thought that he gone soft mocking him.
But the idea is that eventually
this Loki grew as a person
and realized
that Thor had just matured as a person.
When he came back, basically likening
Thor's experience in the first Thor movie
to what Sylvie went through, like her
maturing as a character in That's
why she didn't kill Victor time.
We like, she grew as a person.
she kind of went on a mini
version of Loki's arc.
This is a big argument
that they get into over whether or not
the TVA can become a force for good.
And when Loki starts talking about
how free will is bad, almost like he makes
it sound like free will is bad,
it actually starts to take a turn like,
wait a minute.
No, no, no, that's bad.
What are you talking about Loki?
this is probably something that
they'll explore in the final two episodes
because Loki sounds like
he has like 90% of the correct idea.
But then when he starts talking about
how you can't just leave people alone
with their own free will,
that actually sounds wrong.
Like this sounds like there's going to be
some big twist in the final two episodes
where he recognizes like, no, no, no,
everybody just needs to have free will
and be able
to do whatever they're going to do.
but when he starts
talking about trying to fix
what's broken, being harder
than just raising things to the ground
and starting fresh, that's
a bit of a callback to like Thor Ragnarok
and also his adventures with his family
and like the first Avengers movie,
like he tried to create his own kingdom
on Earth rather than fix his relationship
with his family.
But this whole conversation is meant
to show you how much Loki has grown
as a person, that he's the person
giving the sage wisdom to Sylvie.
like he's giving her something
that sounds kind of like a Captain America
rousing speech.
Like this is something that Steve Rogers
would be saying to the other Avengers
characters.
Sylvie saying Loki is bringing Victor Timely
Behind the curtain is a Wizard of Oz
reference like the man behind the curtain
Victor timely or he who remains
was the man behind the curtain.
then it's kind of a moot point
because of the way they end the episode.
But at the time,
Loki suggests that they send Victor Timely
back to the 1800s and just monitor him
like they would all the other variants.
Like we could protect him.
We'll just leave him there.
In the 1800s, Turns out he's dead now,
so they don't have to worry about that.
but their whole conversation about the TVA
becoming a force for good
makes it sound like
Loki is going in the direction
that he who remains wanted them to go
in, like he wanted them to take over
for him running the TVA in this kind of
what Loki is talking about doing.
when Sylvie talks about them acting
like gods, and Loki says, We are gods.
He's talking about them
being the gods of mischief.
But also it's kind of a callback to him
during Thor Ragnarok
pretending to be Odin,
pretending to rule over Asgard.
Kind of like he plans
to rule over the TVA, at least right now,
it seems like.
when Rensselaer shows up in the TVA
holding cell with Ms..
Men as she confirms
she's only been gone for a couple of days
or the equivalent of a couple of days
with the time works in the TVA,
it's actually been a little bit longer
than that.
but hunter X5 winds up turning to her side
when she promises them
lives on the sacred time because that's
what he wanted in the first place.
He want to go back to his life then R.I.P.
everyone else because Ms.
Minutes totally kills them
using the same device
that Loki was messing with in episode two
in the real crazy thing about this is it
it seems like she sadistically
enjoys it, like she's getting excited
at watching them die.
now kind of seems
that they're setting her up for some,
like over the top villainy
in the last episode in some crazy death
where they completely destroy her
but this finally explains the question.
What is that drain for?
Why is there a giant drain
in a bunch of hoses in this room
so that they can wash the remains like
the squished remains of all those people
down the drains, turns out the TVA
does stuff like this all the time.
Then Ms..
Minutes basically pays off the title
of the episode, The Heart of the TVA.
When she enters
to all the TVA systems, disabling
or basically sabotaging everything.
There are couple of funny moments.
Victor Timely, Just getting really
jazzed up over coffee like here
have some let's as this awesome moment
we'll just share some coffee together,
some hot chocolate water.
But when.
Hunter X5 prunes this other TVA hunter,
he doesn't kill him.
He just sends into the void planet.
It is meant to be a reminder.
Because of the end of the episode,
they kind of
do the same thing with Renslayer,
sending her to the Void Planet.
Obi figures out what Ms.
Minutes is doing,
sabotaging all the systems
when he says that Mobius
had been downloading unauthorized games.
That's meant to be a reference back to the
first Avengers movie in the Galaga game.
Mobius thought that they wouldn't notice,
but Obi did.
love the way Jonathan Majors does.
Is Victor timely too?
Like when he turns on a dime.
The minute he enters the war room and sees
Renzulli and Miz and it's like, hey,
you survived.
This is so great, so wonderful.
they want to stop him from using his
modifier device to fix the sacred timeline
because they want to prune
all the new branches, basically
threatening to squish him
in that same forcefield from before.
Very small little box.
Then they start paying off that Loki flash
for the time slipping scene from episode
one where he jump forward to the future
and sees Sylvie stuck in the elevator
like she gets stuck in the elevator here
because Miss Minutes invades
all the different systems.
so there's any confusion
about what's going
when they all meet each other here
at the elevator.
In this moment that we saw in episode one,
the Loki wearing the jacket who prunes
the other Loki is the older Loki.
Like the current version of Loki,
he ends up pruning the younger
version of himself who survives
at the end of episode one that's
why after he prunes his younger self,
he tells they'll be,
Don't worry, I'll explain later.
This all makes sense a little while.
Just because Sylvie wasn't around
for the events of episode one
where they explained
how he had to prune himself.
Then we find out where the phone call
came from.
And turns out it was just Obie
down in the temporal core, like,
Hey, what's going on?
Why are you taking so long?
And they have the funny moment about them
reactivating magic,
like taking the dampeners offline
so they can get rid of missed minutes.
But also allowing
them to their magic. Again
that's why they yell at them like
turn them off because them using magic
makes them way more powerful.
love the scene a bigger timely,
also trying to delay them in the war room
by just rambling on and on
about the science behind his technology.
lucky stalls them by going fool
Charlie day meme board just going on
and on and on.
they take Ms. Minis offline.
They didn't kill her.
They just briefly deactivated her.
She'll be back
and probably more pissed off than ever.
I love the effect to like she turns into
like a much more primitive clock
right before she goes offline.
in when she tells Victor
timely he'll never become he who remains
even though she
it sound like she wants to taunt him
like he'll never be as great as him.
it's really meant to spurn him on
and give him the courage
to go out on the platform himself at
the end of the episode, even though R.I.P.
he winds up dying.
it's also meant to be a reminder
that Victor
Timely is a completely different variant
with his own
life, makes different choices and.
His future will look completely different
than he who remains future night
that the magic's been turned off.
They can have that funny scene of Loki
and Sylvie versus Hunter X5 like,
shall we have a rematch where she winds up
enchanting him to prune Renslayer,
sending her to the void planet
who will find out about in episode
five like she's still alive.
She'll be back.
Also is pissed off as Miss minutes
Victor timely then uses his temporal
or like basically his temporal thumbprint
to unlock all the TVs systems down here.
Normally
you think it'd be a little bit different
because he's a variant,
so he's from an alternate timeline.
So shouldn't his temporal aura
be a little bit different?
there's a little bit
of hand-waving there from Marvel.
They do that all the time,
especially in big movies
like we only have two and a half hours
to explain this story.
So we're going to hand wave
across a lot of these logical details.
but I love the way they end this episode.
Like it's such a WTF kind of cliffhanger,
like they build with this big
swell of hero music for Victor
timely version of Kang
and then boom, he turns into spaghetti
the instant he steps out in the platform.
R.I.P.
the whole idea
here is that he didn't get pruned
like he didn't get sent to the Void plane.
He was literally like, erased
from existence at all points
in the timeline or a Boris was warning
Loki it during episode one.
Like if you don't wind up
pruning yourself in time,
you're basically erased from
all existence, all across the timeline.
Then basically what's happening
here is the loom collapses like you see
this big explosion where all of time
begins to collapse on itself,
meaning that all of reality is collapsing,
which is why it goes from that
really WTF music and just slams to black.
Just utter silence in black That's meant
to represent the void of nothingness
that is now the MCU multiverse.
Like there is no sound, no light, nothing.
all of existence in the MCU multiverse
just ended.
this is meant to actually be a pretty
accurate representation of what life
was like for Noelle, the God of Symbiotes
when he was born before the Big Bang.
So like,
he comes from this void of nothingness
that existed before the Big Bang.
They basically call it utter chaos.
it's also the place
where the dark elves came from
to There's only one new outro scene.
Like all these different scenes
were in the last week episode.
The only thing that they changed
were the files.
All the files are scenes from episode four
and because Victor Timely died
during the episode,
this thumb probably belongs to Hunter B-15
There's a scene of Loki
running through the hallways.
There's a scene a Victor Timely
about to put the space suit on.
There's a flashback of Renslayer with
he who remains right after the Kang
Multiverse war
This is a scene of or a Boros meeting.
Victor Timely and then a scene of Mobius
in across the rest of the credits.
They just have a very anxiety, hair
raising kind of music like, crap,
what are we going to do now?
So the early theory is, like I said,
they're going to have to reboot
the timeline
the same way they rebooted the TVA.
getting back to the whole concept
of the aura burrows with time
repeating like this big loop of time
That's why they made
so many jokes about it during the episode
Let me know in the comments, though.
How do you think that they're going
to fix things in episodes five and six?
Like how does everything come back?
maybe, maybe.
Early theory Loki Also time slips to
another point in time before this happens.
And wherever he winds up slipping to,
he winds up being able to change things,
preventing this from happening.
but the other big question is,
do you think this is
the last we've seen of Victor
Timeline's version of kink or will we see
a completely different
variant of Kang in the future episodes?
there were a bunch of Easter eggs
and references during the episode,
if you spotted any
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments.
My Episode 5 Trailer
video will post this weekend
and my full Episode 5 video will post
next week after they release it.
click here to watch that video,
Update the link
as soon as I post that and click here
for all my other Loki episodes.
Thank you so much for watching everyone.
Stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!